yeah greg in the last hour police in
riot gear and swat teams have moved in
to the protesters who were gathered
outside this entrance
to one of the chambers at the capitol
building for the last couple of hours
they moved in with tear gas uh
and flashbangs and they have managed to
clear them successfully away from uh
the entrance where we understand windows
have been broken and of course where we
saw those scenes earlier
of protesters uh storming the building
and getting into the chambers
members of congress having to be
evacuated and given gas masks there is a
standoff at the moment now
between police and remaining protesters
some who've been shouting things like
traitors
and trump won has definitely calmed
down here uh it's really down to just a
few hundred hardcore protesters
that are left but there were thousands
here until around half
an hour ago it has calmed down here but
of course it has been
surreal scenes here today one improvised
explosive device
at least one has been found and rendered
safe
rendered safe in the grounds of the
capital and of course as we know
uh one person was shot by
law enforcement but absolutely surreal
scenes here are one of the most iconic
buildings
in america to see it engulfed in chaos
like that
and as we saw from president trump not
only today at his rally
but for months now when you're president
of united states
words matter
sally there on capitol hill thank you
very much for that well you might say
the seeds of what happened today were
sown
on election day just over two months ago
but perhaps
it happened far longer ago when a
maverick outsider candidate
became president of the united